oh my god
hey everyone I used to curry here I am
super excited because today we are going
to be making a baked penne primavera I
love anything that you can use fresh
vegetables in I'm a mom of three so
getting my kids eat their veggies is key
this dish is great because you make it
all in one skillet boil some noodles
toss it into a baking dish and pop it
into the oven there is nothing like a
one and I currently have a pot of water
boiling when it gets to a rolling boil
I'm gonna salt that water you want it
salty like the sea toss in some penne
and at the last two minutes of cooking
I'm gonna toss in some block block Lee
I'm gonna toss in some broccoli florets
and some carrots and let them cook a
little bit let's move on to our veggie
medley
I have here some bell pepper some onions
and some garlic we are going to dice up
the bell pepper dice up the onion and
mince the garlic let that get nice and
hot now we're gonna add in our onion
we're gonna add in our bell pepper here
and we'll let this cook down for a
minute or two and then we'll add in our
garlic the key with garlic everybody
thinks you need to throw it in at the
beginning no he throw it in sort of the
middle through cooking so that that
garlic doesn't burn and you get all
flavor no bitterness let that cook down
now we can go ahead and add in our
garlic okay now I have some crushed
Tomatoes here I'm gonna go ahead and add
that into my skillet
again layering that flavor with a bit of
salt oh and some more pepper I also have
some oregano that I'm gonna add in here
just a teaspoon now our sauce is going
to simmer those veggies are gonna
continue to cook and while that's
happening I'm gonna go and get my pasta
my broccoli and my carrots alright I'm
gonna go ahead and add in some
mozzarella cheese I say some but I'm
adding it a lot because who doesn't like
cheese I then have some ricotta cheese
this is really gonna bring the pasta and
bind it together since we're gonna be
baking it and then our gorgeous pasta
sauce here we're gonna mix this all
together get everything whoa nice and
combined looks gorgeous alright that
looks fantastic look how easy that is so
good okay so now I have a baking this
year and we are going to go ahead and
spoon in our pasta primavera right into
our baking dish honestly it doesn't even
have to go in the oven but it's going to
because we're gonna top this with some
parm and this is going to get nice and
bubbly and brown in the oven all right
let's get this bad boy in the oven I'm
getting hungry
alright everyone so this pasta dish is
done the best part about this is you
don't have to stop here before it goes
into the oven if you want to put in some
protein chicken shrimp steak you name it
you can throw it in there and pop it
into the oven it doesn't have to be
vegetarian now I'm not gonna stop there
we are gonna garnish this pasta dish up
and I love when garnish serves a purpose
it adds a layer of flavor it adds a
little bit of color and depth to the
dish
I have here some fresh basil and this is
actually from my herb gardening can't
sit back to the roots you don't have to
live on
to have fresh herbs and produce and feel
like you're doing something and growing
something you can do it right from your
windowsill so I like to call this from
windowsill to table so we're literally
gonna take this from our garden here a
quick tip with your herbs to release
those oils and that flavor is to give
you the clap it releases the oils it
smells so good and then I'm just gonna
tear it alright and that's it
our pasta dish is done look how gorgeous
all that's left to do is give it a taste
a little winner see you guys next time
[Music]